[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to the
third lesson of ink anomic the splatoon
to guide series where all teach you as
much as I can as much as I know about
the game and today we're gonna be
talking about gear in splatoon too and
how to maximize your chances of
acquiring the best abilities as well as
why your splatfest tea is the key to
success now if you haven't seen the
first two lessons I talked about
movement and weapon choice so feel free
to watch those come back here and if you
want to catch more splatoon 2 videos
guides gameplay consider subscribe to
the game spot it would help me out a lot
and by the way thanks to all you guys in
the comments during the last video I
appreciate all in any feedback and
corrections the Dooleys are their own
weapon type I know this now but anyway
enough chatter let's get to the meat of
this video which is the gear in splatoon
- it's a beautiful complicated beast and
I'll go over as much as I can in the
haunted time I have here now the
clothing in this game is gorgeous and as
fresh as ever
everything from the stitching and the
hats and jackets to the soft rubbery
soles of the shoes look great and so
every single piece that's in the game
has a main ability and up to three slots
for additional abilities and every time
you level up that piece of gear you'll
get a random ability with certain
abilities being more common with
specific clothing brands now as far as a
hierarchy goes in terms of what
abilities are the best my favorites are
ink resist swim and run speed an ink
saver for your main weapon ink recovery
up and also special charge up now these
abilities are great in that they'll
always be beneficial to you no matter
what weapon you use and their benefits
are pretty obvious you know ink saver
for your main weapon basically reduces
the amount of ink being used for your
main weapon and ink recovery same thing
no special charge up increases your
special charge when you're shooting now
ink resist is a little bit more complex
in that it reduces your damage taken as
well as increases your speed when you're
walking in other people's ink now there
are others that are still good but are a
little bit more situational and I
consider those to be the ink saver
for your sub the sub powerup the special
powerup and the bomb defense up now the
effectiveness of these abilities will
depend mostly on your weapon sub weapon
and special choice like ink saver and
bomb defense are pretty straightforward
in what they do sub powerup is a little
bit more vague but it does increase the
range of throwable weapons it increases
the durability of the splash wall the
jump speed of the squid beacon and even
how much ink the sprinkler spits out and
special powerup will actually change
from weapon to weapon as well for
example it will widen the tented
missiles targeting area the blast radius
of splashdown it increases the health of
the baller and it'll increase the
duration of all the other specials
including the ink storm they have
stingray that ink-jet the bomb launcher
and ink armor all right and then there
are the ones that I just really I really
do have a hard time justifying the use
of these and these are the special saver
a quick respond the quick super jump and
cold-blooded and so the first two the
special saver and the quick respawn they
are good but they're tied to the idea
that you will get splatted and they're a
way for you to help bounce back from
that and now while that's good early on
you know when you're still learning in
the game and you get splat a lot but as
you get better at the game and as you
get splat less these will become a
little bit more obsolete now the same
goes for the quick super jump in that
you won't really be using it outside of
the spawn most of the time when you use
a super jump is to go back into battle
but for an advanced technique you might
be jumping from one side of the arena to
another every now and then but for the
most part I would say don't invest too
heavily on that and as for cold blooded
that will require the other team to
actually use point sensors and ink lines
and those are probably two of the least
used sub weapons that I've seen in the
game but you know if you're seeing a lot
of people using it and you're really
annoyed by it then by all means spec
into cold love it but wait that's not
all there are also a bunch of unique
abilities that are exclusive to gear
slots that you cannot receive through
leveling up so what that means is that
some of these unique abilities will only
be available on a certain of gear type
so for example opening gambit and
last-ditch effort those abilities are
tied to headgear mean that you can't
have both at the same time so you're
gonna have to pick one
or the other now haunt ninja squid
thermal ink and respawn Punisher are all
shirt only abilities and stealth job
objects shredder and drop roller are all
abilities exclusive to Footwear so
choose wisely because I would say anyway
those are my thoughts you know those are
my opinions and many of the abilities
will be better or worse depending on
your weapon and mode of choice so for
example something like a quick respawn
might work better in splat zones and
Rainmaker whereas something like last
ditch effort actually works really well
in turf war because so many of those
games are determined in the last 30
seconds and one more thing to keep in
mind is that you can stack non unique
abilities but their effectiveness will
have a diminishing returns like I know
it might be tempting to just deck out
your gear and your favorite ability but
really it's best to try and make a
balanced set instead of going like
all-in with swing speed or a quick
respawn so the next portion of this
video will be talking about the
customization of gear and basically how
difficult it can be every piece of gear
can have three random abilities and
there's only a small chance that you'll
actually get what you want so if you
like the rock'n berg style which is
actually really cool but it's common
ability is the run speed up and maybe
you would like a special charge up
instead you're gonna have a little bit
harder time while you can use a meal
ticket from crusty shan to actually
increase your chances of specific
abilities appearing on your gear you're
gonna have to grind out a lot of salmon
run or find tickets in single-player and
even then it's not guaranteed
so this is where merch comes in and he's
the guy right next to the lobby and what
he'll do is you pay him and he'll
actually scrub your gear for you
meaning that he'll take off all the
abilities that you acquired turning them
into little chunks to be used later and
so what this does is that allows you to
re-roll your abilities you can regain
new ones every time you fill up the
slots and say you're not happy with it
you can visit them and help get rid of
them all for you and so after you're
done with that after he takes off all
the chunks you can go into this menu
right here and you'll be able to apply
the scrubbed abilities to new gear now
this allows for a pretty high level of
customization but it comes at an
incredibly steep
price customizing your abilities won't
require ten chunks for the first slot 20
for the second one and a whopping 30 for
the third meaning that you're gonna have
to scrub a ton of gear and at twenty
thousand coins per scrub this is gonna
cost you a lot of money a lot of time
and getting exactly what you want will
not come cheap however this is where the
splatfest e comes in there is a cheaper
option for the at least for the time
being
so the first splatfest is this weekend
and while the internet is going on about
whether ketchup or Mayo is better your
splatfest e is actually the key to
success regardless of your condiment
alignment as you can see here I joined
team Mayo which means I'm the scourge of
the earth and nobody will ever want to
be my friend but I'm okay with that
because during this period merch will
give you the option of scrubbing off the
abilities from the splatfest t for only
2000 coins and that's that's what ninety
percent off so what you want to do with
this is use this as much as possible
during splatfest you can only wear this
t so every time you get three of your
abilities you want to immediately go
back to merch scrub them off and start
all over again like it won't even matter
if you get your favorite three abilities
on the spot st because you're gonna have
to give it back at the end of splatfest
anyway so what you want to do is just
use this to farm as many ability chunks
as possible the shirt itself doesn't
matter all that much it's just a pawn in
the grand ability chunk farming scheme
so if you're trying to farm some ability
chunks to customize your gear soif s is
the perfect time to do it and also one
more important thing just simply playing
the game during splatfest will also earn
you the super sea snails now these are a
currency that allows you to add ability
slots to your gear so once spot Fest is
over you can actually go over to merch
and you'll be able to trade those super
sea snails and expand any piece of gear
that has less than three slots so get
those cream basics out of the closet
because we're gonna make them look all
shiny and new but really the main idea
is that you don't want to settle on just
one set of gear for every weapon you
know you want this may be stack ink
savers for your charger and splatling
loadout but maybe for
like a shooter you want swim speed and
ink resist so you can go in and out of
danger quickly you know it's mostly
about mixing and matching abilities with
maybe a focus on one or two abilities
one or two main ones but the rest you
want to have supporting those as well
alright that's all I've got for this
lesson I really hope you guys enjoyed
the entire economic series I'm really
loving how excited people are about
splatoon too in general and while this
will actually be the last lesson for now
I can assure you that economics will
return in some form in the future so
please consider subscribing so you don't
miss it when it returns if you have any
other questions about the gear splat
fast the drudgery of scrubbing here I'll
be in the comments below answering as
much stuff as I can as many questions as
you can throw me so thanks for watching
and I will see you squids
next time